on this week's show how to buy a
property without viewing it in the news
Samuel lease launches a brand new
property short on Sky TV and will get
about seeing all your property related
questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
EADS I'm Alistair Cunningham and welcome
to this week's property investors
podcast with a great show coming up
including how you can buy properties
about even viewing it yeah we are which
is pretty insane how you doing my friend
you well I'm I'm very very good I'm very
good what have you been up to this week
I've been I went to the shops of it I
bought those shirts yeah so did I yes I
did actually I went to I went to Hugo
Boss I've got a massive seal on at the
minute
like shorts that are long 160 pound own
a 69 quit really and some of my yeah so
I bought like world's 69 mmm that's good
it's not bad for Hugo Boss shop no it's
very very good Hugo Boss I've had this
one on for three weeks now but yeah I
just bought I bought I liked it so much
I bought I bought lots of them oh yeah
[Music]
so I took I've been speaking to Porsche
and they've informed me my delivery date
for my new car mmm we've been talking
about this for ages yeah but it's been
you ordering you call you have to wait
months and so delivery date is expected
either the 27th or 28th of this month of
July so that is in like that is in not
very long that isn't like a week's time
not far away my friend not far away in a
week's time is it lands at Porsche and
the 26th Porsche Porsche and you know I
get a track D I can take a friend so
Nate do you wanna come home now you've
actually asked him though you have to
honor that
you've asked him on film I'll take you
thank you can you can you come in film
that's what I meant
could you that'll be really good
actually we need you're gonna need to
come with me too when I pick the car up
to film it 100% really yeah a bit
pompous in it yeah okay you gonna turn
up in your old Merc okay my my oldest is
so funny I was that was that with him
the other day and his old Merc he's just
got no power to it no it's he put his
foot to thing it's like he was
overtaking this lorry and it was like
the engine management lights come on and
I'm not spending any money on it because
I just don't need to because I'm gonna
get a new car in the month but I'm like
today when I was coming in to film this
this episode I come out the Tollbooth on
the m6 and it like there was loads of
cars next me and you know it's like
you've got a massive way drawed and it's
like an open space it's just the boy in
you wants to like just read the not-so
avenge Drive and it's just ridiculous I
put my foot flat on the floor in sports
mode and it took like 14 seconds to get
to 50 miles an hour
it's just pants and I got lorries
driving past mean everything lorries
undercutting you prey March and then
beeping at me because I'm in the way but
yeah I'm face but let's say I get my new
car and in a week or two so that's good
awesome and awesome
all right so ha property viewings yeah
realistically is it possible to buy a
property without viewing it yes okay
explain well you just because you don't
view it doesn't mean not something else
hasn't viewed it obviously someone so I
know so many investors that couldn't
Luke couldn't assess a property if it
smacked them bang in the face they
wouldn't know what to look for they've
gone look at it but they don't have a
clue what they're looking at so why do
they need to come if it's if it's a pure
investment property why does it matter
if you view the property because all
you're interested in is numbers
you're not interested in what it looks
like you're not interested in emotional
purchase you're interested in numbers so
why does it matter so why wouldn't you
use somebody who knows what they're
looking at and knows what they're
talking about what get them to view it
for them I'm looking for a pen to click
Nick tells me after clicking the Panda
apparently you guys as viewers find it
and I mean is this really annoying yes
click yes if it's annoying impale them
in the comments tell them Russell you're
so annoying clicking that pin okay if I
do click it just feel free to tell me so
there's two ways isn't there I don't
know or might depend - yeah two ways so
the one is on a you've got a lot of
overseas investors yeah that work you
can use a sourcing company yep have you
used a sourcing company they are going
to obviously view it for you but they're
also gonna get an expert then in a quote
of the work they'll also get helping you
power team finding all that and they'll
put everything together and I'll oversee
it all yeah so that's one way yep the
other way would be to find some what so
you do it all yourself but you find
someone to do the viewing for you yeah
absolutely yeah so how do you find
someone right last week's episode we
talked about how to build a power team
yeah part your power team as a build on
so a my builder if I want him to look at
a property for me I ring him up and I
say hey man I've got this property I
want you to look at can you go look at
it I want you to give me an all round
consensus of the property tell me what
its going to need were quite rough
estimation on cost and he's gonna spot
stuff that I warm spot hmm so when I
look at house I can spot all the obvious
stuff cuz I've been I've been her own
builders all my life my dad's in the
building trade my family's in the
building trade so I know what I'm
looking at however I build there looking
at it will always sports stuff that you
don't because they just do they know
exactly what they're looking at and they
can price up as they're going so they
can tell you like for instance yeah it's
got it needs five doors but also the
fire the door frames are not
particularly right so they need changing
as well and they can do all of that at
the same time so I'm I wouldn't be I
personally wouldn't wouldn't view
properties myself and they said unless
I'm in the area
but if I've got our property up wherever
that I can't view I'll just ring a
builder up and say look I need you when
I look at this house for me and I would
get somebody else to do it
because it makes no difference to the
investment if you do or you get
something else to do it and you're not
the expert looking at properties they
are you're the expert analyzing the
numbers and investing your money into
that property so don't become a busy
fool like do you not mean running around
the country looking all these houses
I mean maybe do it to begin with so you
know you look that's what you've done it
you can say you've done it but I
wouldn't do it on a regular basis would
you go with the Builder maybe for the
first couple of times yeah but then you
build up a bit of a trust with them you
know that we're not gonna rip you off
then it comes back to people and it
comes back to trust I think hmm did you
build up because obviously you simply
simply said they were we're looking at
building up our team builders are
normally pretty busy he's a builder
happy to go into view is how much they
charge you for that no I've never paid
my bill that woman cut property for me
never because y'all knows that if you
get if it if effort if it will fit you
but you'll get the work but I don't take
the I don't take take advantage of them
I don't I'm not having I'm looking at
ten houses a week I'm talking about like
maybe one or two a week or one or two a
month for instance it's not they're not
learning you're not talking many you
know Lords but if you're looking I mean
there is there is services out there
that will provide you this speak to
speak to your letting agent they'll
probably want view it for you
so if you find a hater more manager
nearer and you got hate you more
potential just bring up and say look
I've got this potential would you make
one viewing it for me they might charge
your forty five quid or thirty quid away
about tomorrow you'd almost rather pay
them because then you can use them as
much as you want come up with some sort
of agreement where you are paying them
so you're not taking the mick and let's
just see you live down south into
properties in Liverpool you really want
to travel all the way up to Liverpool to
look at one house or say 45 quid no and
if I'm looking at houses you all alone
you would save me custom or cost you
more but if I'm personally out looking
at houses for the for better sourced I
book a minimum of 12 Ewing's and a day I
won't go on this as a minimum 12 Ewing's
the reason being is because I guarantee
you and this is from experience for will
cancel office annoying or you'll turn up
an agent won't turn up guarantee is
probably more we are there viewings or
what couple weeks
and we had like 11 12 viewings boots and
like we won't actually saw six houses I
had 12 the other day so for there you
are then it happens so and it's like on
the on the way down so I wouldn't manage
to get access yeah you like do you know
one that really bugs me is when they say
the tenants wouldn't let us in happens
all the time I arrived I mean if you
give me one 24 hours it's because they
haven't given the notice yeah but I
arrived up HMO property about a month
ago and they would be given noise they
were all sent text messages seen
somebody country through the house and
we went in and the tenant student
hallway and point-blank refused us
access to house he said I'm not letting
you in this house it says my home you've
not given me notice even though we've
sealed we saw him text he was I'm not
happy when you view my property because
I've got guests here and so you're not
viewing a property new Ben lesson and we
had to just leave whose I can think
guests were probably as I don't know
gone guess a speculate maybe his partner
but so boy so yeah our partners in their
Japanese guests were if he stopped it
come on you don't gonna do that unless
you've got something to hide he was had
a question on in there also yeah there's
something going on because it was loads
of them hanging around and there was
like probably loads of drugs and hookers
I don't know whoever I was like I've
seen it'll be for let me throw it and
thank me come on I'm not me I'm not in
the middle of all this but no just kind
of on the edge of what you know you know
yeah watch watching in but you you don't
have don't become a busy food where you
have to be the expert everything yeah
used your strengths and be do what you
do well and pay all the people to do
what they do and view in properties you
don't have to do yourself so a good tip
for finding people to view problems is
let an agent and builder another one is
like I I put a post out Angie you have a
list of what you're looking for to tell
them I have view in inspection forms so
this is a form this is what you're
looking for great view it and so I put a
full lot of stuffs on your view no
special form what boilers in there what
this what heating system what what's the
condition of bedroom one two three four
five room sizes is a fire doors as no
fire
what the front door that was back tall
that was the roof like was the ground
that was to fall in like there's Lourdes
at 78 pages and so I have I put a post
out on that cold as follows you around
you had back let that go for about three
weeks okay no excuse me guys so I had a
I put a post on a Facebook group in
Liverpool when I needed somebody can
view some houses and normally in all the
cities they'll have like had a tradesman
group or a builder's group whatever and
I just let you pet post house in Luke I
mean I'm an out at town out of town
investor looking to buy properties in
this area I'm looking for somebody who
can go and price up some work for me and
also view the property at the same time
for me and give me an assessment on it
I'm very happy to pay but understand
that if I buy the property you'll get
the work and I I was inundated with
messages people like yeah we can go and
view that for you no problem and I even
if you just pay him 20 quid or whatever
that is so easy to do this it's so easy
yeah
and when I hear people like from London
or like well I can't get to the property
at all why just get something to do it
stop being trying to be the the the
person because everything in your
business yes no it's a tip I learnt from
you always be thankful for it because
you taught me systemization and you
taught me how to get other people doing
stuff so yeah bang on thank you yeah
Steve complimenting each other no I'm
sure as well oh yes this is so nice
it's now time for five pretty thank you
it's time for this
[Music]
so in the news this week
Samuel is launches a new TV show on Sky
General 189 channel one eight nine one
eight nine TV show yep
it's exciting isn't it I think it's just
guys guy
it's exciting stuff man has made it on
Sky TV it's very cool good so that's
every Tuesday night 9 p.m.
first the first show which is a week or
so ago now was the America challenge but
obviously on yuge it's quite important
YouTube but it's it's a different edit
so yeah that was four episodes put
together it's all put together into one
one be shows quite it's quite an
entertaining quite entertaining watch
bring it all together I mean yeah it's
almost had quite a lot of views on
YouTube it's pretty cool it's actually
made it onto a stream mainstream media
totally yeah sky sky TVs massive
everyone knows Sky TV and they you know
on like one eight nine is the the
property so new Blake it's a property
channel now it's being creative isn't it
which is very cool yeah so cool there's
a property property channel it's cuz I
saw everyone wants a no property in its
so in at the minute so I wonder if fur I
wonder if they're looking for a new a
new weekly podcast style you know chat
show you maybe I'm I wonder if they know
and as only we know that could possibly
do that sort of do like a chat show
couple of you know I don't know I don't
know if that would be popular if they
could find two incredibly handsome
fellas a handsome bit of banter great
dress sense yeah that seems shots on for
three weeks that could do a that could
do a weekly show looking like it maybe
like an hour shot get some guests on do
it interviews I think so I think it'd be
really good a little studio together
like in like an old manor with like dark
wood everywhere
yeah that'd be quite impressive that
they could be kind of relaxed a bit
banter drink Starbucks coffee and water
yeah bit of product placement and we
don't have any water cuz it's not on the
side still all over the table if you see
so it's just really good
because it's just again Samuel AD and
lots of value to people and in educating
people what I like I mean I know they're
creating a lot new content for it
videographers are really excited because
you know they get to you know put their
stuff our national TV is also picked up
to a new audience of people yeah and I
think it's great the property investing
in general is starting to hit the
mainstream so it's becoming you know
biggest it's a brilliant topic it's
we're being a brilliant country for it
it's a brilliant time for it the fact
that there's good coming you know
mainstream for me but to me this is this
is just a massive like massive sort of
applaud to Samuel to be honest all this
stuff he's putting out there he's you
know how hard he's working at this he's
he's doing all the YouTube every day
seven days a week now there's something
on YouTube now he's got the sky and he's
got all other things going on as well
and it's all to help people with on
their journey yeah it's all to help
people so like massive hats off to the
guy awesome man
right it's now time for this
[Music]
okay so it's time for questions and
answers so our first question this is
coming through from Instagram by the way
if you want to follow us on Instagram
I'm at Russell leads are you SSE
double-l then leads elderly yes and he
is Alistair underscore coming home I'm
not even gonna attempt to spell it
because you'll get it wrong so Nick will
put a link al Asda IR underscore see you
and n ing a champ that's it when you say
you're not gonna tempt about it because
they'll get it wrong yep but if you were
spelling it
I surely they find limit let me tell you
it's because yeah al al al it really it
is de AR but everyone think so everyone
will think I'm they won't understand
letters ah yes the accent yeah yeah we
talked me about this for the whole my
life when somebody says to me spell
spell my name so I say yeah al Asda IR
and they're like e l es d yeah yeah and
it's like the Michael McIntyre's yeah
the jewel the Geordie are they pronounce
vowels
alright so Geordie they pronounce a e
yeah and they pronounce e a yeah you now
everyone thinks I say my YZ sounds like
my aids and my ace enemies and I just
yeah yeah yeah anyway the master first
questions thing my friend this is from
hyper source and the question is why is
the podcast so goddamn good well it just
is man because like obviously we've got
two of the best podcast presenters in
the country program and we've just
purchased so charming - Charlie yeah I
mean it helps it word handsome the hamsa
was it helps it were devilishly handsome
and get our words out really well and we
yeah we struggle getting getting
speaking and getting our words out good
dresses we'll get into baking and get
get now you know words are more
important the good dress in some
interests sense yeah so much so we keep
the same shot on three weeks that's true
that's true but thanks man it does mean
a lot to us that we have a hyper source
we love you that we have a lot of good
father wasn't a lot of good
good fans out there so thanks very much
right next question from King adds other
than selling the property
what other exit strategy do you
recommend or selling the only way thank
you
well you could rent it you can rent it
you could remortgage every mortgage it
you could sell it you could change it
and sell and so basically there's only
three in there really
Ceylan remortgage it or rent it well you
could remortgage a camera to get it to
of those who won't go yeah
I mean that's really the only exit you
can yeah everything else falls under
then three things in it sell at rent or
mortgage it so what I lost strategy well
where else would you exit the property
you could it doesn't fall under either
on a lease option
you're still sail on it okay found then
you're renting it you could it's still
it's one of them dudes gonna follow them
to in sale on a remnant that it was
exactly so you're selling at the end be
a rental in the meantime okay yeah but
it's different I do yes you're ending it
[Music]
you rather gonna sail it you're gonna
rent it or you gonna refinance it pull
your money out and then just rent it so
I think I sorta need 23 answers that
question they go King adds there's a
three if I think of any more then I'll
let you know okay next
Jordan Spearman MMA I wouldn't mess with
this guy
ie sounds dangerous just the fact that
he felt the need to put MMA at the end
of his name
well it doesn't stand for Mitch Marsh
mixed martial arts what if it stands for
something else mellow mannered adult
yeah well if it's male well mannered
adult I mean could be you got any good
think it could be and I don't want to
just in case it dust and for MMA right
as a deal sorcerer what are the top
priorities before selling a deal to make
it a success I found the deal how the
make sure it's ready to be sold I'll
take this okay so you need to be doing
your due diligence and you need to be
doing it thoroughly
so make sure any old builders go and
view it for you make sure the deal
stacks up make sure your numbers are as
close to post as close as possible make
sure your estimations and build cost are
as close as possible make sure you've
got good proofs of demand in the area
and unless ability make sure you have a
para teaming area make sure let ability
it will look forward yeah let out mate
word I don't know I made up either way
it means let out and make sure make sure
that the the property works as an
investment property and it's in a good
ear a good condition just do your due
diligence and because ultimately you
want to be sure that if you're passing
that on to an investor for two or three
thousand pound fee that you've done your
job and what isn't it okay fine it's not
what but you've done your job could be a
good name for a company that let ability
imagine if you had a little n agent say
ok so just make sure you've done your
job because you've got to justify your
fee so it could be as simple as that
you've managed to negotiate ten thousand
pound off the law of their the value
don't negotiate in ten thousand off the
asking price does not negotiate in
10,000 burn off the value so if you
negotiate ten thousand pound off the
value and you print presenting that to
an investor and they're gonna pay three
grand for it absolutely because they're
still going to make seven grand it's
just things that that just make sure the
deal stacks make sure it all works make
sure you've done your research make sure
you can back your research up so if an
investor wants to see it you can give it
to them I give all my investors the
information once they paid a fee for the
research we've done it's all as always
available for them and just make sure
one of the biggest things I do if I
personally wouldn't buy the property I
wouldn't sail it to an investor is that
it's that clear to me um but all all
always bear in mind that my strategies I
really buy B by B for a be financed and
I wonder what in a specific area so the
reason I passed deals on is because I
don't want them all over the country I
want my properties in a specific area so
you wouldn't buy them I wouldn't buy
them because they're not in my specific
area not because I'm not bad deals
they're good deals they're just not in
my strategy so
so I would I would I'm great you're
getting to it don't I'm not gonna put
you through it right so just to confirm
what Russell was trying to get out and
just because I don't buy all the deals
does not mean the bad the reason I don't
buy all of them is because one I've not
got an endless pot of money and secondly
they don't fit my specific strategy
however if my strategy was in that area
I would buy that deal so if I was buying
a Newcastle and I had a good deal come
up in Newcastle and it all worked if I
wouldn't buy that deal I wouldn't sell
to an investor so that's how I do it
thank you can you add to that no as an
investor what would you want to see what
from the I just want to see everything I
need is know and want to see the
important stuff that gave me the number
so I want to see how much it was how
much it was to buy how much it was gonna
cost me - if I had spent any money on it
yeah and what my rent is gonna be and
details with being in a good area I'd
also want to see that I was paying I was
paying the right price for the property
yeah the true market value and evidence
of that it's just really you know
evidence that I was making a good
purchase yeah one thing that we'll see
about investors you I talked about this
from stage there's several different
types of investors you've got proper
investors and then you've got amateur
investors and people that don't really
know what they're doing now proper
investors the the deal very much is that
what you've just said they want to know
that's a good deal it stacks up amateur
investors want to do they want to know
the color they want to know like things
that they shouldn't don't really need to
know and what I love about dealing with
investors I deal with is they're all
proper investors they they're in they're
in that's it this is what I want these
are the numbers of what they look at
numbers that's all they look at they
don't care that the walls are blue the
the back gardens D read in a way over
all they care about is money in money
out and and if you can find investors at
that your job will be easy because
they'll value your time whereas I find
amateur investors they're always morning
about like a sourcing fee they're always
morning that the build costs an extra
thousand pound away over because the
track do if they're gonna
which there's nothing wrong we do not on
a budget but I have more problems with
amateur investors and reduce use
investors and that's why we're they
picky with who we work with cool
question okay so we've got a question
from Mitch X fit and the question is any
tips on fully systemising your business
yeah so i systemized better sauce
completely so I spend literally a
probably thirty minutes maybe I don't
let you say thirty minutes a day so it's
a system as it can be but my involvement
is whatsapp messages to the management
team so systemising the business you get
a management team in place you put
people in place and you give them
control hmm and from me that was very
hard because you remember what I was
like I used to hold on to everything I
was like no no no if it what if I need
to do and I've got to do it because copy
they'll be done properly when I learnt
to release that control and let people
do it to you we help people do it as in
run the business and it went well and I
I know I'm like you did a better job of
me you do it I love it and so use use
people and employ people virtual
assistants companies such as five or all
these sort of people to do all your
marketing all that sort of stuff all
your business cars or stuff it's very
very easy system as a business and but
you don't need to do everything yourself
remember that yeah so what I would say
is first of all is you want you want to
create like a like an organized a I
talked about this a lot it might
soon-to-be-released
boot book first thing you wanna do you
want it you want to put your structure
in place you want to work tasks that you
need to do then I'd pick the ones that
you hate and systemize those first yeah
so depending on your personality type
who knows that obey and then only get
only get people to do the jobs that only
get people to do it that do the job
better than you do mmm-hmm is the first
yeah also if you know if you can get
someone doing your accounts make sure
they're gonna do a better job of it than
you and just a tip whenever I'm hiring I
think it's always very easy fast air to
do this but bit more difficult for me
but just just hire people are going to
do better than you
and then just work your way through
through the lessons start replacing
yourself in those jobs and just making
sure that that they're doing they're
doing a good a good job
yeah the certain stuff but I think it's
difficult to ever fully replace I think
marketing is one that within marketing
you've got different tasks so you've got
you know some some of the stuff a lot of
it you can a lot of it you can replace
yeah but I think it's hard to fully
based on that but obviously obviously
you can do the bigger you grow it the
more you can be writing everything down
and just taking off the things that you
don't like doing and that's that's
really good because what happens you
won't do those things anyway and also it
lets you actually realize what your
business involves like they it's amazing
if you actually wrote down one this one
to one hundred of what what you actually
do in your business it'd be amazed at
how many of them jobs are like do with
the minimum wage your job you'll
struggle at first and then when you'll
start really did this and you'll start
adding to the list
it might take you a week or so to fully
get the list right but so problem I've
got it a minute is all my social media a
note about oh sorry different things
yeah character that was personal sorry
I'm sorry all my social media messages
and arts or stuff they're just the teeth
it's taken I'm getting a lot I'm getting
a lot instant messages I'm getting I'm
getting loads of messages and emails so
I'm a bit I'm busy and I'm going to need
some that help me with that so to me me
reply into every single email is I don't
need to so I'm gonna have somebody look
at my emails and work at what ones I
have to do what ones they can do and
that's just partly systemization your
contacts with people because seven
waiting three days for a reply they can
get a reply within a couple hours yeah
and obviously the emails are addressed
per thing to me where I'll address but I
get many many emails every single day
from people that like you know you have
a pa pa is a good PA is a good person to
get first because they're kind of with
you and you can just give them the task
yeah yeah if you're gonna hire someone
I'd hire a PA first mhm before you go
for anything else you don't even have to
go for our physical PA you cannot
virtual ps4 if you need one like maybe
two hours a day you can have a virtual
PA for not a tremendous amount money
yeah yeah so they've answered your
question
psalm systemized a business there was
another question her eating Tom can I
have a good book I can read to
understand the very basic principles of
property investing I would say buy low
at high by Samuel Leeds is a great place
to start with the basic skills
Alistair's books also very good he
looking at deal packaging yeah putting
yourself out there and finding deals
yeah it's called whatever it takes
but for just the basics of property
investing I said boiler it has a really
good place as soon as Russell's boots
come Russell Russell's boot comes out in
a couple of months
it's called as it am i right and Cena
similar to name it as they name it or
tell them the name you don't name if you
want to know if you named it yet I said
what we've talked about the
entrepreneurs blueprint that pretty much
so Russell's got boot coming out called
the entrepreneurs blueprint and it's
it's about the business side of things
so that is also a very good book to get
and read to for the business side of
your properties yeah sure yeah brilliant
well guys like them so much for tuning
in I've enjoyed filming the show to the
show we'll be back next Saturday at 7
p.m. we will see you
[Music]
[Applause]